is also on the scene of a deadly
stabbing in the east valley this is
happening at an rv park right near
flamingo and boulder highway sasha
loftis there with what police say
happened
ryan this happened quite a few hours ago
and you can see police are still
investigating here at this rv park they
tell us this started as an argument and
ended with one man stabbing another here
officers tell us this happened around 5
30 this evening they were called here to
the roadrunner rv park and found a man
in his 60s on the ground in front of his
rv with multiple stab wounds police say
another man was standing nearby and
witnesses identified him as the suspect
he was then arrested that victim was
taken to the hospital where he later
died officers say it's important for
those living here to know this wasn't
random they say the two men arguing did
know each other now back out here live
officers are still trying to figure out
what started this fight and what led
later to the murder
at the roadrunner rv park of course this
is still a developing story so a stay
with 8 news now both on air and online
as this continues to develop reporting
live tonight sacha loftis live local now